well a couple in Idaho claim to have new
details in the mysterious case of a
missing Colorado mother and a possible
murder plot Joe and patty rocks all say
they called the FBI after learning
disturbing details about the
disappearance of Kelsey Bharath they
claim they learned the information from
a close friend of crystal Lee Lee
allegedly had a relationship with
Barrett's fiance Patrick Frazee crazy is
now charged in Barrett's murder even
though her body hasn't been found
Nika batiste is here with the expanding
twisting and turning investigation Nikki
good morning good morning good morning
everyone
a source tells CBS News the FBI
questioned crystal Lee regarding her
possible role in Kelsey bears
disappearance and that she is
cooperating with authorities her alleged
connection to Patrick Frazee is offering
new insight into what may have happened
she was in love with him from a very
young age
Patty and Joe Rock Stoll say one of
their employees who is crystal Lee's
best friend told them that Lee and
Patrick Frazee had a relationship that
began just after high school she was
very vulnerable and I think she cared
for him and he took advantage of that he
was her first love I understand and he
had a hold on her The Rock's dolls say
they were told Lee a nurse from Idaho
and mother visited Frazee as recently as
November the month his fiance Kelsey
Bharath vanished they claimed their
employees says freezy threatened Lee and
she may have helped him dispose of
evidence do you know what the threats
were Patrick told crystal that little
girls go missing off the playground all
the time crystal was so scared he was so
angry that he said things that made
Krystal think he had killed before so of
course she's going to be terrifying the
rocks dolls say they were told Frazee
Ashleigh three times as early as October
to help kill Bharath but Lee refused
from what crystal said what was Patrick
Frazee's motive that he felt that Kelsey
was going to harm the child that she was
crazy
it's crystal Lee a murderer I don't
believe so I don't
Bharath was last seen on this
surveillance video at a grocery store in
caller
on Thanksgiving Day with her in Frazee's
one-year-old daughter three days later
police say Bharath cell phone pinged
nearly 600 miles away in Gooding Idaho
several texts were sent from the phone
including one to her employer saying she
would be away for a week and another to
Frazee do you think crystal Lee sent
those texts I do
she had the phone she was probably
instructed to send those texts by
Patrick but that's there's nobody else
that could have sent those texts to my
knowledge
why would crystal Lee a nurse with
children help Patrick Frazee cover up
the murder of his fiancee I think she
was afraid and I think she got in over
her head she was in love with Patrick
and we've all heard the stories of what
people will do for love the rock styles
have never met crystal Lee in person she
hasn't had not been charged with any
crime related to Berens disappearance a
jury trial for one of the two wrongful
death suits Frazee is facing is
scheduled to begin one month from today
thank you rock stars for speaking up and
glad to hear that crystal is cooperating
yes and we just before Kelsey's family
that our bodies bounced yes we really do
thank you Nikki